one of the biggest questions in Return
of the Jedi has annoyed fans for years
why didn't Obi-Wan just tell Luke that
Darth Vader was his father in the first
place he started out as a pretty cool
old guy showing him fancy laser swords
in his creepy desert Hut but then he
straight up lied to Luke about who his
father really was well guess what turns
out it wasn't Obi-Wan's fault it was
Yoda who confessed the truth on his
deathbed here's how the final cut of
that scene went not ready for the burger
for you
I'm sorry but the original version had
an extra line that took all the blame
off Obi-Wan not ready for the burn
[Music]
Obi-Wan would have told you long ago
Yoda purposefully kept the secret from
Luke even forbidding Obi-Wan from
telling Luke out of fear what Luke would
do if he knew the truth